[Music]
okay so it's official we are totally in
love with a hit Netflix original movie
the kissing booth so we did a little
digging and found out some secrets that
will leave you shook stay tuned to find
out some awesome deets about the sequel
if you're as obsessed with movie secrets
as we are be sure to subscribe to the
things and give this video a big thumbs
up and now it's time for 10 awesome
facts about the kissing booth I love
real-life love story we love the
chemistry between Al and Noah in the
kissing booth they grow up together and
Noah is always there to watch out for
Ellen Lee Noah becomes a super popular
guy in high school and he'll totally
pines for him but she can't pursue her
feelings because she and Lee have a rule
about it on the first day of L's junior
year Noah gets into a fight with some
guy who decides to grab Elle without her
consent oMG he is such a hero these two
have some serious romantic vibes and we
think it's because they dated in real
life seriously their instagrams were the
cutest while they were still dating
Jakob oh lordy who plays Noah even held
Joey Kings hand at the dentist
no wonder they played such a realistic
couple in the movie in June 2018
Joey flew cross-country to surprise
Jacob for his birthday unfortunately
looks like they may have split up there
has been a lack of photos in July 2018
which stirred some rumors that they are
no longer together we can't say for sure
but if so we hope they work things out
jacob oh lordy is not from the US we
were totally shocked when we found out
Noah Flynn has a fake American accent
the actor Jacob oh lordy is from
Australia his American accent is so
convincing it totally had us fooled
who is jacob oh lordy anyway he hasn't
been acting very long he got his
professional acting start by playing the
cat in a hat in a stage production of
Seussical the musical then he starred in
two short films and even wrote one
called Max and Iosefa he also played an
extra in the 2017 film pirates of the
caribbean dead men tell no tales
but the kissing booth is what's launched
him to fame he even learned how to ride
a motorcycle for the movie he loves his
fans and keeps his Instagram
active and he's a whopping six foot four
inches he can act
do accents right and ride a motorcycle
so hot there's nothing he can't do
since he's so talented his IMDB page
seems pretty busy with future projects
so we'll be seeing a lot more of this
Australian babe it's moments like this
that make me wish things could stay this
way forever
all grown up the kissing booth will
probably be remembered as a pretty
awesome teen movie but we're totally
shocked to find out that the stars of
the movie are actually adults they play
such convincing high school students
Jacob oh lordy aka Noah Flynn turned 21
on June 26 2008 teen Joey king who plays
Elle Evans will turn 19 on July 30th
2018 so she's not too far from the age
she played Joey's been acting since she
was really young
her first credit on her resume was
actually two episodes of The Suite Life
of Zack and Cody but you may recognize
her more as Ramona from the 2010 movie
Ramona and Beezus her IMDB schedule
looks crazy busy so we'll be seeing a
lot more of the 18 year old actress as
well the most shocking age was Joel
Courtney who played Ella's best friend
Lea Flynn he was born on january 31st
1996 which makes him older than the
actor who played his older brother yeah
he played a character much younger than
he really is and he did a great job at
it you might remember Joel from the 2011
movie super 8 we can't wait to see what
else he'll work on in the future stunt
double you normally expect to hear about
stunt doubles in action movies not in a
teen romantic comedy but in the kissing
booth at least one scene needed a stunt
double at the beginning of the movie Lee
played by Joel Courtney does a giant
cannonball from the second story of his
house into the pool in a live tweet
session joey king revealed that they had
to use a stunt double for the scene the
jump was high and the water was too
shallow which of course makes it
incredibly dangerous for any normal
human being
remember when noah falls out of L's
window or what about when l had to jump
out of noah's window onto a trampoline
and she ended up falling into the pool
with all her clothes on speaking of the
pool you know that impressive house
where the Flynn's live the house they
filmed in actually has four swimming
pools yeah pretty stellar but why would
you even need for swimming pools
movie icon arguably the most famous
person in the movie is Molly Ringwald
who plays Noah and Lee's mom Molly was a
member of the famous brat pack the 1980s
stars of teen movies in the early 80s
she starred on the TV show the facts of
life then she played Samantha in the
famous teen flick sixteen Candles one of
her most famous roles was Claire
Standish in The Breakfast Club we caught
a couple of Breakfast Club references in
the kissing booth
in that detention scene they're all
dressed like the kids from the classic
movie and at the prom the song don't you
forget about me
plays as they walk down memory lane this
song became famous from the Molly
Ringwald classic Molly's also starred in
pretty and pink in 1986 we as Molly
Ringwald just loves teen movies in
television because she's also starring
as Mary Andrews on the popular show
Riverdale we love that she is such a
teen flick icon okay now we need to go
binge some Molly Ringwald movies it was
filmed where the kissing booth is set in
the Golden State
aka California specifically it takes
place in the trendy city of Los Angeles
but it wasn't actually filmed there you
would think it was because of all the
beach scenes convertibles palm trees it
even has a scene at the Hollywood sign
and the fact that most movies are filmed
in Los Angeles but this one wasn't it
wasn't even filmed anywhere close to LA
with the exception of just a few scenes
the majority of the movie was shot in
South Africa of course Cape Town South
Africa is the Beach City too so it makes
sense that it looked so much like LA one
of the scenes that was actually filmed
in LA was the Hollywood sign teen Noah
takes Elle there and tells her she's the
first person he's ever brought up there
they set the rules of their secret
relationship and then they kiss Joey
King says she made a lot of friends
while she was filming in South Africa
and she can't wait to go back and visit
we are amazed that they filmed the movie
halfway across the world yet it feels
like it was an authentic Los Angeles
movie think that's crazy
stay tuned for a huge surprise at the
end teen movie tributes the kissing
booth breaks several teen movie tropes
Elle is a strong independent girl who
doesn't tolerate being told what to do
by Noah and we love that the movie shows
that you can be friends with the
opposite gender without ending up in
love with them but the movie sure knows
its roots there are several scenes
throwbacks two other classic teen flicks
we already mentioned all the 1980s Molly
Ringwald references but wait there's
more first of all a kissing booth is a
major plot point in she's the man
starting amanda Bynes and Channing Tatum
those two totes adorbs and there are not
one but two scenes that play homage the
iconic 90s movie 10 Things I Hate About
You starring Heath Ledger and Julia
Stiles
you can draw character similarities from
both movies especially when it comes to
the representation of unpopular girls
and the spontaneous paint fight scene L
has with Leigh in the shop that is also
a tribute to 10 Things I Hate About You
who could possibly forget about that
paintball scene we love how much respect
the kissing booth paid to all great teen
rom-coms that came before it ELLs real
name it may come as a shock to you what
else real name is we know what you're
thinking Noah calls her Shelly and she
hates it so that must be her real name
right nope the kissing booth is based on
a book by beth wrinkles in the book the
main character reveals that both Elle
and Shelly are nicknames her character's
real name is Rochelle Evans they don't
even mention it in the movie not even
once and Rochelle is a beautiful name so
we're not sure yl hates it but L Evans
definitely has a ring to it
Elle isn't the only character who
doesn't go by the real name Noah hates
going by his first name
everyone at school knows him as just
Flynn which leads to some major drama
and confusion at the kissing booth scene
they couldn't get popular Noah to
volunteer so Elle brings the other Flynn
brother
it's sad at first as most people are
outwardly disappointed but it works out
well for Lea who ends up with a
girlfriend who really likes him and it's
nice to Elle because that's important
we're glad that Lea gets a happy
storyline even though he has a rough
patch with Elle author cameo the author
of the kissing booth is pretty awesome
Beth Rickles is only 22 years old and
has already released three other books
she first published the kissing booth on
Wattpad which is a website where anyone
can write and read other people's work
it had 19 million reads on there then it
was picked up by a publisher which is
every writers dream
Beth Regals is really talented and
successful how cool is it that she was
given a cameo at the end of the movie at
the costume party scene at the end of
the movie you can see Beth she's all
dressed up like a 1920s flapper what did
Beth rickles think of a cab
she loved them although she said they
didn't look exactly like she pictured
them but once she met them she realized
that didn't matter she thinks they were
perfect
Jacob oh lordy smirk was exactly how she
pictured Noah's smile to be we're glad
they did her book justice and so glad we
got to see her in the movie even if it
was just for a second doesn't that make
you want to read all of her books do you
think she'll have more of her work
turned into movies possible sequel
Netflix hasn't announced whether or not
they will do a sequel that there's a
good chance they will first of all a
companion of Ella to the kissing booth
already exists on Wattpad it's called
the beach house and it takes place the
following summer there's a bunch of
drama with Elle and Noah dating while
Lee is there must be super weird to have
your best friend and brother dating Joey
King has also said she was more than
willing to do a sequel and so is the
actor who played her little brother
also the authors tweeted out polls to
gauge interest in a sequel do you think
the sequel will be based on the beach
house or would it be a whole new plot
either way we are super stoked about the
prospect there is a huge fanbase of
readers and now there are a ton more
fans who love the movie hopefully with a
movie success Netflix will decide to
listen to fans and produce the sequel do
you want there to be a sequel and if so
should it be based on the beach house
don't be shy let us know what you think
in the comments and that's it for the
shocking facts about the Netflix film
the kissing booth be sure to subscribe
and check out our community page
[Music]